hey yo what up wisecrack
chris here to talk about something
that's been dishing out fatalities since
1992.
that's right
[Music]
now we're longtime fans of the game and
even have a soft spot for the often
ridiculed 1995 film
so we are pretty jazzed for our 2021
reboot and the opportunity
to hear get over here on the big screen
but as the end credits rolled
something just wasn't sitting right
don't misunderstand us
it brings a certain level of fun and
spectacular blood squirting
and that might be all you want from a
mortal kombat movie which is fine
but we'd argue that the movie
misunderstands a basic appeal of mortal
kombat that the 1995 version mostly got
right
we'll explain in this wisecrack edition
on mortal kombat what went wrong
and spoilers ahead for the mortal kombat
extended universe
and before we jump into it i wanted to
give a shout out to this week's sponsor
raid shadow legends if you don't know
raid is an awesome hero collector rpg
where you can collect champions and
battle up against friends or players
online
we've been playing raid for a while now
here at wisecrack so we've been able to
collect a lot of champions
some of my faves include the epic battle
stage and the legendary astrologe
they are essential to my clan battle
sage places an increased attack buff on
all allies
and removes all debuffs on allies and
places a revival on death buff
for all your teammates which can be so
helpful collecting heroes and building
up my team is one of my favorite parts
of the game
you can really plan a strategy before
heading against some of the tougher
campaigns
the game is constantly updating so
there's always something new to do
this month they've released 11 new
amazing champions and now there are
almost
200 brand new missions to complete with
an exclusive legendary champion as your
reward
if that's not enough they added five
tough new levels to almost
every dungeon ready to play some raid
and check out everything the game has to
offer
click the links in the description to
download the game for ios android or pc
today and now back to the show to
understand what makes for a good mortal
kombat film adaptation
we first need to look at what made the
game so beloved in the first place
beyond the basic game mechanics there's
a joy in discovering all the fatalities
the seemingly inexplicable pop-up of a
guy saying
and uh je ne sais quoi of impaling your
opponent on a floor of spikes
mortal kombat differs from other
fighting games largely because of its
blend of humor
self-awareness and joyful
over-the-topness
in everything from the costume design to
the character concepts
compare that to a competitor like street
fighter a relatively straightforward
fighting game that while featuring a
green dude who electrocutes you
generally takes itself pretty seriously
by contrast whether you're turning your
opponent into a
literal baby or just turning them into
your new best friend
mortal kombat fully embraces the
ridiculous even and maybe especially
in its most violent moments and the 1995
film followed the same ethos
and not just when you are watching a six
limb puppet get owned by a single punch
to the groin
from its set design to his performances
the film is nothing if not over the top
in this way both the game and the
original film are excellent examples of
the
camp aesthetic and i'm not talking about
bent tent poles and damp sleeping bags
now camp is a word that gets tossed
around a lot in film buff circles
but it's worth really examining what it
means as helen
a shugart and catherine egley wagon
explain camp is an over-the-top
playful and perotic aesthetic and its
use of the exaggerated ostentatious
outrageous
renders it effectively a spectacle
though camp has become virtually
mainstream in recent decades
appearing in everything from desperate
housewives to buffy the vampire slayer
it originated in queer subcultures as
far back as the 18th century
the aesthetic became a way to use camp's
irony theatricality
parody and humor to cope with and combat
social stigma
in susan sontag's notes on camp she
identifies the camp aesthetic in various
cultural products
ranging from tiffany's lamps to actress
greta garbo the unifying theme here is
that they all broadcast their own
theatricality and artifice
the films of john waters are also a
prime example of
campiness delivering wretched often
filthy excess with a lucille bluth style
wink
all in all camp is simply put too much
man
camp culture in some ways is an attack
on
high culture according to sontag in that
it asserts that good taste
is not simply good taste that there
exists indeed a good taste
of bad taste now campiness permeates
just about every frame of the 1995
mortal kombat film
that's why even though the film was not
particularly well received when it first
came out
it's retained a serious cult following
the reasons become clear in the opening
moments when we see an over-dramatically
rendered fight
framed in over-the-top canted or
dramatically tilted angles
it's punctuated by sound effects that
are much too loud
and rounded out with absurd performances
like your brother's
soul is mine oh and then his face turns
into a skeleton and if that's not
too much i don't know what is when this
guy's eye full-on twitches
that's camp when a giant skull appears
in the sky through
less than convincing cgi effects that's
also camp
this what more do you want
total camp and when the camera literally
tilts under this guy's crotch just as
he's uh
asserting his masculinity you better
believe that's camp but did the
filmmakers do all of this on purpose
that question raises an important
tension within the camp aesthetic
intentionality according to sontag
sometimes camp is completely naive
happening by mistake and resulting in
failed seriousness
the room of course is an absolute master
class in this you're just a chicken chip
chip chip chip cheep jeep
other times as with any performance by
the actress divine in a john waters film
the campiness is the intention the
creators are in on the joke
what's interesting about mortal kombat
is that it feels like we're seeing
instances of both kinds of camp within
one film
which is pretty unusual the campy
performance by christopher lambert as
lord raiden feels pretty purposeful
there's just no way he wanted you to
take his character completely seriously
if seriously at all in moments like
these the film feels like it's
self-consciously trying to be camped
it's how do you say
a deal's a deal
what have you done i made a choice as a
means of leaning into the video game's
absurdities
but there are other moments where you
can sense a failed attempt at seriously
carrying out a cinematic gesture
like this divine moment when a ninja
comes up to fight but trips over himself
just a little bit moments like that
a failed seriousness somehow make the
film more lovable
the absurdity of mortal kombat's camp
aesthetic is a big part of why it's
remains such a cult classic
fatality oh and also heads blowing off
this is why we were puzzled to see how
the screenwriter behind the remake
approached retelling the story
he told polygon that with something like
mortal kombat where we're talking about
soul sucking sorcerers
it can very easily slip into camp so
right away he's rejecting some of mortal
kombat's dna
he continued i love the 95 film but it
drips in nacho cheese
but we were in 2021 and we wanted to
deliver a movie that felt more authentic
a little more realistic i mean realistic
isn't the first word that comes to mind
when i see this
but okay the decision to lean out from
the camp factor is not subtle
the overall aesthetics of the newest
installment are less colorful
less zany and less punctuated with
over-the-top set designs
instead and despite clearly having a
bigger budget the new film exercises far
more visual restraint
settling for darker barer shots and
simpler production design
also quite a bit of it takes place in
the real world
which is depicted quite unremarkably the
camera angles air on the side of
conventional
as compared to its predecessor's
aforementioned widely canted angles and
occasional crotch shot
the total differences between the two
films are obvious from the first moments
of the new film
which don't include the glorious theme
song but rather set up a true family
tragedy
in the 1995 version when liu kang sees
his brother get murdered
the fighting is over the top rendered a
near total caricature by the
performances
it's not trying to tug at your
heartstrings in the new version a woman
and her child are murdered off-screen by
killer ice guy in a moment conveyed
through this guttural cry for help
her husband upon finding them dead seeks
a tearful revenge against the attackers
only to tragically be defeated here
they've built up a genuine drama which
sets the tone for a film that is
definitely
not going to embrace the goof factor
except mortal kombat isn't supposed to
be about killing people's families
it's about melting a person's face with
acid and it feels like a bit of a
contradiction to make a determinantly
serious and gritty film when you
literally have a character whose
magical power is having a killer hat we
can also see these kinds of problems in
more
one-to-one comparisons take the whoever
kano is murdered in each film
in the first he's put into a deadly
crotch hold says
i'll give you a prank and promptly has
his neck broken by the sheer force of
sonia's thighs it's ridiculous it's
goofy
in the new version he's stabbed in the
eye emitting a guttural moan as he
collapses to his death
not exactly a law moment similar laws
were lost in the new film's depiction of
goro
our favorite four-armed pal now i tear
out your
in the first he's an absurd puppet who
likes wrestling and has a penchant for
going like
even when he kills it just feels kind of
funny as do the characters reactions to
the death
in the new version goro's a scary cgi
concoction who literally hunts down the
main character's wife and child
gone is any trace of the originals himbo
charm
when summing up our criticism of the new
film it's worth considering another
quote from sontag's seminal essay
when something is just bad rather than
camp it's often because it is too
mediocre
in ambition the artist hasn't attempted
to do anything really outlandish
this seems to sum up the problems of the
mortal kombat remake to a t
it's a gore-filled film full of insanely
over-the-top action but infused with
zero sense of humor
other than the occasional lame crack
from kano arms dealer
drug runner murder for hire scum of the
earth
i also give really good foot massages
and one great shout out to the game's
most annoying strategy not the only
movie you know mine
in this way the film fails to hit the
mark of outlandish
in the way that its predecessor did so
beautifully but what do you guys think
are we being too harsh on the remake is
the 1995 version outdated or as lovable
as ever let us know in the comments
as always thanks to our patrons for all
your support hit that subscribe button
like you're splitting someone in half
vertically with a deadly hat
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
peace
[Music]